what's inspiring your new music that
you're writing right now oh I think mmm
when I walk to like a park and I see
like some of the background like trees
and like plants I think that background
inspired me really bad yeah that's so
beautiful
you guys are like romantic thank you
tomorrow bye together dishing on new
music to ET and gushing over bebe Rexha
and yes BTS I know you guys also said
that you really loved bebe Rexha oh yeah
I'm a big fan of her I love her songs
because her own songs has a really good
message so when I listen to her songs
I feel touching I feel really touching
how you love BTS for how they really
pave the way when I feel like you guys
would break the internet break the world
if we could get a collaboration with BTS
is that something that could ever
possibly maybe happen yeah Mike maybe we
want yeah yeah if we can we want to have
a collaboration with BTS yeah I think
first of all they gave us lots of advice
and their performance is really good and
we went to Chicago and met them there
and we saw their concert and it was
really amazing they inspired so much and
we admire them thank you fashion is
incredible did you plan this out
together ahead of time right we yeah we
have
Sal has made us for a made it for us
yeah for only this moment - oh we our
stylist made this clothes for when go
tango yeah thank you thank you
how was the tour what was your favorite
thing about touring yeah of course
meeting our fans and doing ours yeah six
showcase it was so amazing and we went
to many place like Venice be Santa
Monica
it was wonderful place in fresh air it
was awesome we caught up with the guys
at their first-ever Wango Tango
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]